tras años de aterradoras sequías gran
parte del estado de California se ha
visto afectado durante la última semana
por el aumento entre el 400 y el 600% de
la media en sus precipitaciones causando
graves daños materiales cortes de
Electricidad y obligando a mieles a
evacuar sus hogares
celo fatigados que están todos pero por
favor mantengan un poco más de
vigilancia en el transcurso de los
próximos días y superaremos esto luego
volveremos al trabajo que se debe hacer
para asegurarnos de que podamos superar
lo que está sucediendo las potentes
tormentas invernales han desatado
lluvias torrenciales vientos
inundaciones y peligrosos deslizamientos
de tierra algo que no había sucedido en
una década pero no todos son malas
noticias en el condado de Santa Bárbara
algunos de sus habitantes celebran que
el lago cachumba ha alcanzado su máximo
nivel de capacidad tras días de lluvias
incesantes generando esperanzas a un
estado que debe someterse constantemente
a racionamientos de agua por la falta de
lluvias
en 2016 el lago llegó al 6% de su
capacidad y ahora Estamos de vuelta al
100% por eso decimos que la conservación
es una forma de vida en el condado de
Santa Bárbara porque no importa si
llueve ahora Necesitamos conservar el
agua es realmente la mejor solución para
eso es que las personas asuman la
responsabilidad personal de usar menos
agua entre tanto las autoridades se
mantienen en alerta máxima para evitar
mayores desastres pero también Para
aprovechar cada gota para sobrevivir a
un verano que amenaza con causar fuertes
estragos